one of the biggest Microsoft games at
Gamescom is crackdown 3 which is
bringing the series back from xbox 360
and returning to form for the first game
sort of avoiding a lot of the things
that people didn't like about the second
game and so what do these things include
well it's got a lot of verticality they
brought back little emblems that you
collect to boost your agility and you
know firepower but there's a lot more
than that call now yeah we went to see
at the Microsoft booth at Gamescom and
there's a lot of maths happening in that
game which is what I came away thinking
and it's impressive to me that the
entire thing is didn't fall over it
immediately so I look the the demo that
we had was of the destructibility but it
does have a multiplayer specifically so
fuel yeah yeah so it's important to make
that distinction the level of
destructibility that they're telling and
showing off doesn't translate to the
entire game right it's just the single
player is just normal yeah and then when
you get into my player it goes into this
crazy cloud powered computational driven
distractibility game you had way better
insight into the magic that was
happening behind it whereas from a
layman's perspective I saw them taking
rockets to this huge building and
systematically taking down one side of
it so it was really weighted to the left
yeah and then it crumpled and then
toppled over and then smashed a building
next to it and then there was just a
pile of rubble which other agents were
jumping into like it was a pile of gold
or something yeah and just stuff going
everywhere yeah so there's a lot of
things going on that make this really
special one the destructibility alone
does create a lot of you know it's
really tasks the processor there's a lot
of computational things to happen and a
normal Xbox one could not really handle
that to the same degree that this was I
mean we were able to whittle down a wall
using a machine gun yeah so what they're
doing is they're leveraging multiple
servers and they had a little scale that
showed you the equivalent power of Xbox
ones that were being used they got up to
13 Xbox ones essentially being used in
the cloud to allow this to happen
and what's also important is that this
is happening in a multiplayer
environment so it's not as though you're
playing on different cloud servers that
are then trying to communicate together
everyone is playing on the same server
so you have destructibility and
deformation that is sort of parallel
across the board for everyone
he's playing which is a pretty big deal
you know one thing I found really
impressive that I'm not sure how problem
is in terms of technology and why
whether it's being used everywhere was
the way they switched to a debug menu
and they were within a small block of
the city and different different
buildings were colored differently and
he said the different colors represent
different servers so let's say there was
a blue and a green together he shot the
the blue building and as debris from the
blue building crossed over it would
change color to the green so essentially
what it's doing is it's taking bits of
the destruction and moving it around
servers yes it's the map it's
essentially a parallel processing which
is what you would see and some of the
super computers back in the 90s where
you'd have like you know a thousand
computers linked together all working on
one computation and I also by the end of
our persistence yeah which a lot of
people were wondering whether you know
it stays like that what happens when you
go into a city and it's you know
someone's already totaled it and because
it's multiplayer only it's all about
sessions yeah so the moment you leave
the sessions that kind of stuff is all
is all done but as long as you stay in a
multiplayer session you can blow up a
portion of the city go away and come
back and that portion will still be
blown out yeah I can have fun in there I
mean it was really cool to see this but
I think there's a bigger discussion at
hand which is the fact that this
represents a possible future for console
gaming and when I asked them if they
believe this is the future for console
gaming their answer was yes yeah and I
think the important thing there is that
one you're not actually paying for
expensive hardware you'll just be able
to pay for a small device and pay for
subscription service that can tap into
this power yeah and what it allows you
to do is then experience things that
aren't limited by a generation of
hardware companies can literally ramp up
as new hardware is released just you
know to the to the commercial market but
you don't have to pay for it yeah from
like a gameplay and presentation or
Adeste that's the science part of it
done yeah but like from a gameplay
perspective it seems like it was very
much in line with
first crack down but you have these gang
leaders who are given more of a presence
in the world with this digital lair
thing the new single in the
single-player yeah yeah so in the
single-player like you have these gang
leaders which are essentially hunting
down and you need to kill them and they
have this like system where they were
the angrier they get the more they
appear in the world is there a hate
meter yeah it's like coolly hey Mia and
in the example they showed us it was the
agent and eventually they hate me a
filled and a large like projection of
the triad guy with his face off Miller
just appeared and was like dude I hate
you so much
yeah not in those words but essentially
that and then they're talking about like
having that presence of gangs way more
around you in the world so you always
know what you're fighting for
yeah like in the past in the first game
you had to search for them you'd get
there it was really just a firefight
that as long as you'd like didn't get
hit you could essentially take out the
boss pretty easily once you found them
but one of the the bosses that we showed
us during the demo he was like in a mech
right and you couldn't just throw a
grenade at it cuz he would shoot it out
of the air you had to use more advanced
tactics like find a vehicle knock the
mech over and then shoot that crate
that's hanging from a crane and have it
fall on top of him yeah so then you
could finally disable it and take him
out the traditional way so there is a
more advanced complex system going on in
cracked yeah that's creativity of
tackling what your missions extends for
like the physics episode like for
example where you talked about you might
have a player rate or that you're
hunting or another gang leader at the
top of a building instead of jumping all
the way up you just thought with your
team chipping away at the foundations of
the building we can bring down the
entire thing and see if that takes care
of him or
so that's that's much that's not very
play yeah players that plays at top of
the building that you want to bring down
that's not exactly what I want to do
when I played the first crackdown it was
all about causing as much mischief
around me and kind of taking making it
difficult for the other players in the
game so I would wait for them to like
reach the very peak of a building where
they want to collect an orb and just
shoot a rocket directly at if things are
not Sam all the way back down that's
what I want to do yeah and in that game
definitely enables that yeah so
crackdown right now you've got a little
bit of them revisiting the past and the
single-player stuff that's done on your
Xbox one and then looking into the
future with cloud computing for the
multiplayer aspect with incredible
destructibility and things that just are
not possible
with a single console and there's a lot
more games coming from Gamescom 2015
it's almost wrapping up but we're not
done yet
so stay tuned to game spot calm
you